اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه عن استشهاد
الشاب حمزه بشكار برصاص قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي امس على حاجز حواره جنوب مدينه
نابلس من طول كرم ينضم الينا مراسل
الجزيره ليث جعار ليث ماذا في حيثيات
وتفاصيل استشهاد الشاب حمزه
بشكار نعم يعني وزاره الصح الفلسطينيه
اعلنت عن ارتقاء الشهيد حمزه ابو شكار من
مخيم عسكر في مدينه نابلس بعد يعني
محاولته تنفيذ عمليه طعن عند حاجز عورتا
المتاخم لحاجز حواره الى الجنوب من
المدينه مدينه نابلس تم احتجاز جثمان
الشهيد وا الاحتلال اعلن فيما بعد عن
ارتقائه شهيدا وابلغ ال وابلغ
ال السلطه ابلغ وزاره الصحه بانه قد تم او
ارتقى الشهيد
حمزه خلال او بعد اطلاق النار عليه بشكل
مباشر عند هذا الحاجز بدعوه تنفيذه لعمليه
طعن ايضا خلال الليله كان هناك اقتحامات ل
مخيم بلاطه جرى خلالها اعتداء على سيده
فلسطينيه في المخيم وايضا شاب بالضرب من
قبل الجنود ما ادى الى نقلهم الى المستشفى
بعد الاعتداء عليهم ايضا خلال ساعات الليل
كان هناك اقتحام لمخيم العين ب عشرات
الاليات العسكريه ومن ثم بعد ذلك تم
مصادره مركبه وهي المركبه التي تم استهداف
الشبان بها امس خلال محاوله استهدافه من
قبل مسيره اسرائيليه على صعيد مدينه طول
كرم كان هناك في ساعات الليل اقتحام ووسط
اشتباكات مسلحه عنيفه ما بين المقاومه
وقوات الاحتلال تم اعتقال خلالها او خلال
هذه المداهمه لشابين ومن ثم انسحب
الاحتلال من المدينه بشكل مباشر